[Music]
good evening it's good to see everyone
here tonight I would like to open with
with the word of Prayer and let's ask
our Savior and our God to be here with
us
Father in Heaven we come to you tonight
boldly and yet humbly father we ask for
your presence and for your son's
presence through your Holy Spirit be
here with us open our eyes that we might
see your glory and our ears that we
might hear thy voice alone father we
claim this property and all of the
equipment and every person that is here
we claim the shed blood of the Lord
Jesus Christ over us and father we ask
that your Holy Angels that Excel and
strength will bind all the powers of
darkness let none of the heathen say
where is our God thank you for hearing
and for answering in Jesus mighty name
Oh ma'am I would like to open with the
text of scripture this evening it's
found in Isaiah chapter 45 and we're
going to read 18 and 19 I'm gonna
abbreviate it but that's where it'll be
from it says for thus saith the Lord
that created the heavens God Himself
that formed the earth and made it he
established it he created it not in vain
he says I am the Lord and there is none
else I have not spoken in secret in some
dark place of the earth
I said not under the seed or children of
Jacob seeking me in vain for I the Lord
speak righteousness I declare things
that are right
just to give you a quick introduction
for 25 years I was an instructor in
Chinese and Filipino and Japanese
martial arts as well as other forms of
Eastern mysticism traditional Chinese
medicine Chinese ki Gong Tai Chi etc
when the Lord set me free from the
bondage that the enemy had me in he did
a number of miracles in my life
restoring my wife and I'd the covenant
of marriage he brought our family back
together
but he did exceeding abundantly more
than we ever could have imagined he
brought me out of this world that even
as the seventh day EV in his Christian I
was going to church every week but I was
going to a different church and I was
teaching in a different Church a
different setting six days of the week
and I remember I asked the Lord after we
had first done the first testimony on
the dangers of Eastern mysticism I said
I don't want to spend the rest of my
life talking about this stuff I was so
happy to be out of it and to be free
from the spiritual influences that have
been working in my life I didn't want to
talk about it anymore I said God you
know we've done the testimony little
light Studios did a film I said let them
watch that I don't want to talk about
this and and God had other plans praise
God and what I found was over the next
couple of years was there were
Christians in every denomination that
began to contact us and many of them
probably 33 percent had had some
involvement in Eastern mysticism or
martial arts but the other 65 percent to
69 percent had never had any involvement
but the reason they contacted us was
they said if God did
this in your life can he set me free and
I started realizing that the purpose
that God had was not just in revealing
facts but in setting every captive free
now I'm going to give you sort of a
disclaimer we as seventh-day Adventist
Christians we were known as people of
the book and the servant of the Lord
told us she said we're almost replaying
the history of what the Jewish church
was doing in Jesus's day do you know
many of them had head knowledge they
knew the facts they knew the Bible
studies they knew the state of the dead
they knew the health they knew tithing
they knew the sanctuary but they did not
know by personal experience the presence
nor the power of God in their lives
do you know that right now many
Christians are going through the same
thing they are finding that like with
the emerging church what what's being
said is is we need to find a new way to
evangelize we're losing
we're losing members and not just in our
church in all denominations so they're
bringing in you know contemporary
Christian rock and roll music
they're bringing in whatever all these
new ways of preaching the gospel because
they have bought into the lie that
that's going to fill the churches people
don't need a new gospel they need the
power of God in their lives that's what
we want to reveal here because when I
when I first was brought out of what I
was involved in I had no idea that that
ten years later this is what God was
going to be having me to share and what
I've found over the past few years from
we were able to speak on the emerging
church and spiritual formation is
oftentimes
we look at the bad we identified the
danger of the Illuminati and the danger
of the jesuits n' and we know what the
mark of the beast is and we know this
fact and that fact but many people are
saying I've got facts in my head but my
heart has not been changed and that's
what Nicodemus was asking Jesus I know
in my head but I want to know your power
in my life that's what most of
Christianity is looking for that's what
Satan is using spiritual formation to
counterfeit he knows that people are dry
the wilderness you know of men's hearts
is dry and God said can these can these
dry bones live yes I have to put my
spirit into them Satan said I'll
counterfeit this I'll make them so dry
that they will accept anything to drink
whether it's kosher or not and that's
what he's doing through spiritual
formation in the emerging church so what
we want to do is we want to take a
closer look tonight we're going to begin
laying a foundation and over this this
entire week over the next few days we're
going to go through and we're gonna
build on that foundation and by time we
get to the end your hearts are going to
burn like they have never burned before
when you see the power of God so
remember that as we're looking at this
we're gonna look at the counterfeit
first
a familiar text of scripture Revelation
chapter 12 and I'm paraphrasing this I'm
reading from the King James but I'm
putting some verses in there together so
I encourage you to take notes and look
these up on your own when you're at home
and when the dragon saw that he was cast
down under the earth he persecuted the
woman which brought forth the manchild
and to the woman were given two wings of
a great eagle so that she might fly into
the wilderness where she hath a place
prepared for her by God that they should
feed or nourish her there away from the
face and the presence of the serpent now
we know who this was in genesis 3:15 God
made a promise to a bur to Adam and Eve
he said your son is going to crush the
Serpent's head a little while later
Abraham came along and he made a promise
to him he said unto you and your son are
these promises made and in your son make
a note of that in your son not by your
son alone but in your son will all the
nations of the earth be blessed and then
King David came along and God repeated
the promise and he said King David of
your own flesh I'm going to raise up a
son and he's going to sit upon your
throne a timeline of prophetic history
growing up as a seventh-day Adventist
Christian I can remember my mother
reading to me those little red books and
I still have some of those same ones but
it was almost like it was something
almost make-believe you know there was
this this little old lady named Ellen
White and and she wrote these things and
it was sort of dis
connected from the real world and as I
started going back doing research after
the Lord brought me out I was amazed to
find out the historical evidence for
what was actually taking place back in
the 1800s and and as I started putting
these things together as the Lord was
revealing it all the sudden the things
the truths that Ellen White was being
shown to share with you and I they
became alive let me show you what what
was happening 1800's the beginning of
this country the Protestant Christians
fled to America the Great Awakening
began the Second Great Awakening here in
the United States there was a very
renewed study and comprehension of
biblical prophecies especially in Daniel
and revelation and this is something
that is a key we also saw the beginning
of a huge temperance movement in the
United States it wasn't just Adventists
when I was even preparing this series
and I had to go back and do research it
was everywhere there were people
everywhere that were standing up saying
we've kind of changed the way we're
eating and I thought it's not funny that
God was doing that in every denomination
at the same time that he was revealing
the truth and the nearness of Christ's
return the same time that he was
proclaiming the 1888 message of
righteousness by faith he had already
been preparing the world through getting
them to change the way they were eating
and living the law of God was being
revealed as unchanging and perpetual and
at the same time in 1888 we had the
Blair Sunday law legislation being
presented before Congress the same year
that the message of righteousness by
faith
revelation 12 goes on and tells us that
the great dragon that old serpent called
the devil and Satan he cast out of his
mouth water as a flood after the woman
so that he might cause her to be carried
away by the flood what does water a
symbol of spirit and words remember what
Jesus said the words I speak unto you
they are spirit and they are life in
John chapter 7 verse 7 through 30 or 37
through 39 Jesus talked about the water
and he said come unto me all you that
are thirsty and I will give you living
water and this he spake of the Holy
Spirit which had not yet been given so
water is a symbol symbolically not only
of people's nations you know which
revelation talks about but more
importantly even in the Old Testament
Scriptures water is a symbol of the love
the Word of God and His Spirit in that
word Satan said the woman has fled the
only way I can get her I can't oppose
her he tried that to destroy her during
the Dark Ages he said since I can't
oppose her and kill her
I'll pour out such a flood after her
that it'll dilute what God is trying to
do now let me show you this is
interesting what else was happening in
the 1800s humanism Frederick and I'm not
even going to try to pronounce his last
name
Natha Homer as spouses critical thinking
and rationalism over dogma and
superstition and when he said
superstition he met religion he
considered Christianity to be
superstition it's it's just like all the
other religions out there
deism Thomas Jefferson
wrote the Jefferson Bible it was
originally called the life and morals of
Jesus of Nazareth that was in 1820
Thomas Jefferson when he wrote this
Bible and we actually have photographs
of the original he literally took
scissors and he cut pieces of the
Gospels out and then he would insert
other pieces of scripture in their place
he did away with the virgin birth he did
away with almost every one of the
miracles that Jesus did in the Jefferson
Bible what Thomas Jefferson was trying
to say was Jesus was a good moral man
but he was not verily God he was not
divine he was not born by the miraculous
work of the Holy Spirit higher criticism
fred frederick shyly mocker he began
using the skeptical examination of the
accuracy of biblical text he was the one
that first termed the coin higher
criticism in 1822 transcendentalism
Ralph Waldo Emerson he's a well-known
transcendental author my son and my
daughter both were in college now and
and they call home and they're telling
me about what they have to learn and you
know when they're sharing this I'm just
amazed at how even today the enemy is
still using these same authors and
figures to influence the thinking of the
new generation Emerson
heavily was heavily influenced by
Unitarianism and by Hinduism I was very
shocked when I realized even in his own
writings the influence that Hinduism had
on many of these people
he gave something called the Harvard
Divinity School address which really
brought transcendentalism before the
American nation in 1838 feminism
this was this was very eye-opening and
one of the reasons that I included this
was because I'd heard a gentleman
professor Walter White that also made a
reference and I went I looked it up
feminism was heavily promoted by a woman
named Elizabeth Cady Stanton she
actually signed the Declaration of
Rights and sentiments in New York City
in 1848 and the table you have to
forgive me I don't remember who it
belonged to but the table where they
signed that document was owned
previously by a high occultist I don't
remember if it was yet to forgive me I
know it wasn't H people of ASCII but it
was somebody that was heavily involved
in the occult and they brought that
table there for that signing
intentionally mesmerism how many people
are familiar with that term mesmerism
that was the old term for what we now
call hypnosis the original term was also
called animal magnetism it did not have
a lot to do with using magnets in the
beginning what Franz Mesmer said was he
believed in studying human anatomy and
science that there was this energy of
electromagnetic force and this force
interacted with everything in nature and
he said if it's in all of nature it has
to also be within us and if it's in us I
should be able to tap into that power
and use it to help heal others so now
when you read where sister white warns
about magnetism there's more there it
wasn't just people picking up magnets
and you know taping them to certain
parts of their body pantheism Henry
David Thoreau was a very strong promoter
of this how many people have ever heard
of his book
Walden or Walden Pond that book is it's
a classic it's an American classic it's
required reading in almost every
University now if you have a literature
class or an English class that book is
filled with Hinduism even the names for
some of the places that he put there all
Indian names and he wrote I found
statements from him and he said of all
the places that I have seen and I have
read the Hindus they have an
understanding of our world and of what
they call God that surpasses every other
religion so when people are reading this
book and they say oh it's just harmless
reading you don't realize you can't pick
a book up and it'd be harmless unless
just you know how to fix your lawnmower
or change the oil in your car if you're
reading a book that has got
philosophical or religious or spiritual
overtones or even political overtones
normally there's a spirit that is
influencing that writing that book was
first published in 1854 spiritism which
means the study of communication with
spirit entities was first introduced by
a man named Allan Kardec he's the author
of a collection of books known as the
Spiritist codification these were
published in 1857 1859 Charles Darwin
first published the Origin of Species
these are a lot of events that are
happening within the 1800s is it just by
chance let me ask you a question
what is the Sabbath the sign of what
does the Bible say it's a sign of that
the Lord God sanctifies us not we
ourselves but that can only be done by
faith the Sabbath is a sign of
everything our our months our days our
years all of those things you can point
to outer space to our planets and our
constellations and you can identify when
the month starts when the day starts
when a year starts you cannot do that
with the weekly cycle it's impossible
God designed it that way the only place
we have a record of the weekly cycle is
from God's Word the Sabbath is a sign of
faith Darwinism took away the seven-day
creation all of these other things
chipped away at the foundations of our
faith at the same time that God was
proclaiming his law of righteousness and
proclaiming the message of righteousness
by faith alone free love ISM this is a
picture of Herbert Spencer he was the
author of a book called the system of
synthetic philosophy he was recognized
as the most famous philosopher of the
age 1869 was when this book I believe
was published 1881 Westcott and Hort
introduced the revised and I'm going to
use that term very loosely their corrupt
version of the Greek New Testament we
don't have time to go into that but that
was in 1881 all of these things were
there because they were undermining our
simple living faith in dust saith the
Lord the free thought movement Robert
Ingersoll he was the reorganizer of an
anti-christian organization called the
National Liberal League it became the
American secular Union this organization
of free thought
they had an influence on almost all of
our politicians and almost all of our
authors in the United States free
thought movement Christian mysticism how
many people have heard of Edgar Cayce if
you go to a health food store you can
still find things that are produced by
the Cayce foundation
Edgar Cayce promoted a form of
spiritualism that he blended or where he
blended the communication with spirit
entities under the guise of Christian
philosophy for healing so he was
blending spiritualism with biblical
Christianity in order to help heal
people now listen to what sister White
had to say desire of Ages page 258 when
Satan has undermined faith in the Bible
he directs men to other sources for
light and power and thus he insinuates
himself those who turn from the plain
teaching of the scripture and the
convicting power of God's Holy Spirit
are inviting the control of demons
criticism and speculation concerning the
Scriptures have opened the way for
spiritism and theosophy if you have
Ellen White's writings on a cd-rom or
you go online and look it up look up the
word theosophy and read the statements
she says about that those modernized
forms of ancient hedonism to gain a
foothold even in the professed churches
of our Lord Jesus Christ this is coming
into our churches across America right
now every denomination every
denomination the birth of spiritualism
and spiritism in America how many people
have heard of the Fox sisters the
wrappings I remember my mom reading me
that you know that and I thought
I mean this was just some little minor
event that happened and you know New
England and you know I just didn't pay
attention as a teenager I had no idea
when I went back later on and began
looking it up there were men and women
of God of every denomination that we're
writing and warning God's people about
spiritualism the Fox sisters lived from
1814 to 1890 a man named Elijah bond
introduced for the first time a board
game which Parker Brothers I believe
bought the rights to called the Ouija
board you used to be able to go to
Walmart or any department store and buy
one it's witchcraft it's not just a game
that was introduced in 1892 years after
the message of righteousness by faith
madam H people of ASCII you see there on
the right-hand side of the screen she
lived from 1831 to 1891 she was there
when sister White was warning the world
about spiritualism and she lived in the
New England states where Ellen White did
so when we read about sister white and
she's warning so strongly about
spiritualism and spiritism this was not
just some dream that she had she was
seeing it it was in the newspapers the
politicians were proclaiming this as
being new light she tells us in eight
testimonies page 290 we are living in an
age of great light and illumination but
much that is called light is opening the
way for the wisdom and arts of Satan
many things will be presented that
appeared to be true the Bible tells us
in first Timothy 6:20 that these are
called opposition's of science falsely
so called in that amazing that too
thousand years ago God already knew what
was going to happen many things will be
presented that appear to be true and yet
they need to be carefully considered
with much prayer for they be specious
devices of the enemy this is Time
magazine and they say the science of
yoga millions of Americans are
discovering this ancient exercise now
here's the skinny on why it makes you
feel so good when I go to our churches
to do presentations on yoga and martial
arts and Tai Chi I normally ask the
congregation how many people here have
had any self-defense training in a
martial art on average we get about 30%
of the the hands I'm sorry about 10 or
15% will raise their hands for martial
arts and self-defense but when I asked
them about yoga or ki Gong or energy
healing or acupuncture normally the
hands go up are 35 to 40 percent in our
churches I just met a pastor recently on
the East Coast a strong man of God it's
got a lovely wife I mean they're a very
good couple and she mentioned something
when she had seen the Dragon revealed
she said what about yoga and I said well
I'll loan you a video you know on yoga
specifically wasn't one that I had done
and she just talked to me this past
Sabbath and she said we watched the
video and I said well did you think and
she said I didn't tell you when we first
talked she said I'm 48 I've been doing
it since I was in high school every week
I had no idea what I was involved in
when you see people doing those poses
who stretches every one of the stretches
is a a symbolic gesture almost like the
hand mudras that gesture invokes a
Hindus
spiritual entity to come into the
person's life and to empower them and
make them feel better and and people say
yeah but it works just because it works
doesn't mean it's of God the path of
error often appears to lie close to the
path of truth it is hardly
distinguishable from the path that leads
to holiness in heaven but the mind
enlightened by the Holy Spirit may
discern that it is diverging from the
right way for after a while the two
paths are seen to be widely separated
now I want you to to catch this I know
we're sharing a lot of quotes but as we
go through this series you're going to
start seeing how these pieces tie
together listen to what we're told as
the right hand of the third angels
message God's methods of treating
disease will open the doors for the
entrance of present truth present truth
is the Sabbath righteousness and living
by faith in His Word by changing the way
that people eat it opens the door for
them to see and comprehend and be able
to take hold as sister white said and
apropriate Christ's righteousness as
their own our physicians in Europe and
other countries should awake to the
necessity of having health works
literature and messages prepared by men
and women who are on the ground and who
can meet the people where they are meet
them where they are this is not talking
about at the mall or at the bank
it means meeting people where they are
if someone has eaten
no pork their whole life you can't come
in and give them the whole health
message in 30 minutes and say you've got
to do all of this right now
you have to take steps you have to
introduce them
and you have to give them the same
freedom that you've had to make those
changes in their lives she says we are
to meet the people where they are with
the most essential instruction that is
necessary for this time this has an
effect what was the first sin that
caused all of mankind to fall appetite
and you know I used to think appetite is
just what am i eating or how much am i
eating
do you know appetite is not just
involved with the stomach when you read
what sister white said she said she was
shown a list of sins
that would condemn people in the last
great day and she said under appetite
fell almost all of the other moral or
immoral transgressions adultery lust
fornication and all the other ones we
don't even want to get into they fell
under appetite intemperance appetite is
something that happens in the mind not
in the stomach it's saying I know this
is what I should do I know this is right
but there is this chemical reaction
that's happening in my brain and
affecting my body and it's overwhelming
and I can't say no sometimes I hear
people I mean they'll they'll write to
us or they'll call us and they'll say
I'm trying to give up caffeine or I'm
trying to give up nicotine I'm trying to
give up smoking and I go to my pastor
and they're like look you're just gonna
have to exercise more willpower I think
we have no idea if I go to some drunk on
the street and I said look you're just
gonna have to exercise willpower he's
gonna look at me and say if it was that
simple
I wouldn't need your Jesus if it was
just willpower one person will get the
victory overnight and another person
will be struggling for 10 years what's
the difference
are we saved by willpower there has to
be more God has got to come Christ has
got to come and take possession of his
temple and change us and he has to cast
out and bring into captivity all of our
thoughts and in the way that we feel and
our chemical reactions he has to take
possession of his temple some of our
brethren have expressed fears that we
shall dwell too much upon the subject of
justification by faith pay attention to
that word justification but I hope and
pray that none will be needlessly
alarmed if there had not been a
remissness in the past to properly
instruct the people of God there would
not now be a necessity of calling
special attention to it to properly
instruct the people of God she says you
have to appropriate the promises as your
own not as something that in the future
one day Jesus is going to give to you
you've got to look and say when Jesus
died I was in him dying right I am
crucified with Christ nevertheless I
live when was Christ crucified two
thousand years ago if you were in him
when he died
you are dead as Paul said and your life
is hid with Christ in God we have to
appropriate not only his death but his
resurrection and not only his death and
resurrection but every victory that he
gained you have to know and I have to
know I was in him and I'm going to show
you the quotes from Scripture as well
from Ellen White before this week is
over you
in him when he won those victories so I
don't tell the Lord Lord I need you to
give me victory over this temptation you
know what he does when I say that he
says Eric I already gave you the victory
when are you gonna thank me for it and
stand up and walk in it
my son I remember you know he's younger
than my daughter
he's 18 now and I can remember when he
was going through high school he'd be
rushing to to get out the door in the
morning and he would come down sometimes
he would say dad I've got 15 minutes I
gotta go I need a lunch for today and he
would be running upstairs I'd be like
I've got the lunch made for you it's by
the door he'd come down in two minutes
after he got out of the shower and he'd
say dad I've got to go don't forget I
need a lunch I say Corner it's it's by
the door and he'd run out of the room
he'd come back a few minutes later and
say ok ok I've got my dad I need my
lunch and I'm like I made it it's by the
door we do the same thing with God
God give me victory God is like the
victory is in Christ ask me to give you
Christ and Jesus is saying I'm standing
at the door knocking if you'll just let
me in I will bring my victory into your
life that's what Satan does not want us
to know the exceeding great and precious
promises given us in the Holy Scriptures
whereby we are made partakers of the
divine nature mark that mark that down
nature put a note in your mind or on a
piece of paper nature that's important
whereby we are made partakers of the
divine nature these have been lost sight
of to a great extent just as the enemy
of all righteousness design that they
should be he is blinding us to the power
that God has given us
he has cast his own dark shadow between
us and our God so that we may not see
the true character of our God for the
Lord has proclaimed himself to be full
of mercy and gracious long-suffering
patient even under the sacrificing of
self and abundant in goodness and truth
several have written to me inquiring if
the message of justification by faith is
the third angel's message and I have
answered answered it is the third
angel's message in Verity I thought the
third angels messages come out of
Babylon the Pope's the Antichrist don't
receive the mark of the beast that tells
us there's more there than what we've
seen do you know in the very end when
Rome influences this world which is
happening right now and they declare a
Sunday law do you know that's gonna be
called righteousness by works not by
faith that's the same thing that Satan
has sought to bring men into from the
very beginning when we were standing at
the foot of Mount Sinai God spoke his
law and Ellen White says every command
is a promise education page 126 every
command is a promise do you know what
God spoke those promises and you know
what man said everything that God said I
can do you know what God says everything
that I've said I will do if you'll just
surrender and let me inside so that I
can do it in your life these are the
words in the Greek and Hebrew
consolidated down for just
vacation and justified to declare and to
render innocent just clean holy
righteous and perfect that's what it
means to be justified to be declared how
does God do anything he speaks it how
did he create the universe he spoke it
into existence how did he set the
captives free when Christ was here
he spoke their freedom do you remember
the Roman centurion Jesus said I'll come
to your house and heal him and the Roman
was not even a seventh-day Adventist
he wasn't even Hebrew he said you don't
have to come to my house speak the word
only and I know it'll be done and Jesus
turned and looked at all those
Christians and he said I haven't found
this kind of faith in all of Israel if
you would stand through the time of
trouble we must know Christ for this is
life eternal and we must appropriate the
gift of his righteousness which he
imputes to the repentant sinner no
glorious to redound to man all human
help and glory lies in the dust for the
truth as it is in Jesus is the only
available agent by which man may be
saved and I remember when I was
struggling to get free from the bondage
I was in when I was in those arts and
and everything else that had happened in
my life and one day I read that verse in
John 17:17 and Jesus said sanctify them
through thy truth thy Word is truth and
in John eight he told the disciples the
truth
you will know the truth and the truth
will make you free and I was like I was
like Lord I was raised a Seventh day
Adventist Christian I don't know what
this means what does it mean the truth
will make me free what does it mean
you're gonna sanctify me through your
truth and God spoke to my heart and my
ears and he said Eric you don't even
know what the word truth means and I'm
there at the house by myself you know
and I talked to God out loud because I
know he can read my thoughts but I like
talking to him he not dead and I looked
up in heaven and I said of course I know
what truth is it means correct doctrine
and Jesus said Eric you don't even know
what the word truth means and I got out
my concordance and on a sword and I
looked up that word do you know what it
means it means unfailing Verity thy Word
is truth it cannot fail that's what he
says in Isaiah 55 my word has gone forth
it will not return unto me void do you
know when my wife and I went through
that divorce that we went through we
were separating divorced five years
legally the judge had signed the paper
and my wife would go to church on
sabbath and you know people would come
up after two years and they would say
Sarah listen you need to just move on
with your life I mean your husband is
gone he's not coming back you're
destroying your children let go and you
know what she would always say she would
say but God made a promise to me what
I've joined together let no man put
asunder
and they were like yeah but the judge
signed the paper she said let no man put
asunder do I believe what that judge has
written or do I believe the Word of the
Living God that's what God wants us to
do when you go to the doctor and he
tells some
badi you love you've got cancer or
you've got diabetes or you've got this
you know there's no hope of recovery
from this you've got to say thus saith
the Lord
I'm the one that forgives all your
iniquities and I heal all of your
diseases I've got to make a choice do I
believe God's Word or do I believe the
word of mortal man I'm keeping an eye on
the clock now we're gonna start getting
into why this matters dr. John Harvey
Kellogg he was an honored member of the
Michigan State Board of Health from 1878
to 1891 and he also was a few years
after that as well
and he was the author of more than 50
books and hundreds of articles on health
and healing he was credited with the
development of corn flake cereal
high-protein meat substitutes
acidophilus and rich soy milk and the
unique process of manufacturing peanut
butter with boiled rather than roasted
peanuts Kellogg is reported to have
performed 22,000 surgical operations
himself and he treated more than 200,000
patients successfully during his
lifetime and his work as a physician at
the Battle Creek Sanitarium some of the
people that Kellogg treated William H
Taft Piercy Granger Amelia Earheart
George Bernard Shaw Johnny Weissmuller
Henry Ford the man that founded the Ford
Motor Company Thomas Edison john d
rockefeller Harvey Firestone JC Penney a
lady named Sojourner Truth CW Baron
where angie warren g harding
and Booker T Washington he was world
known because of
the blessing that God had put upon him
now I want to show you something the
health message is being promoted
strongly in this country and God raises
up a physician who is a brilliant man to
promote this blesses him beyond measure
with with knowledge of how to do the
medical work how to help treat the sick
and its world world known same time he's
raising up Jones and Waggoner with the
1888 righteousness by faith message who
do you think Satan would go after to
destroy with the most evil intent he
says I got to get rid of the health
message because if they understand
health they'll begin to comprehend the
spirituality of the law and the
righteousness by faith and then he said
I've got to get rid of the righteousness
by faith that's why he's separated Ellen
White and 80 Jones and EJ Wagner he sent
Wagner to Europe I believe Jones was
here and he had the conference in Ellen
White against her judgment to Australia
Satan was like divided they won't be
able to work together they won't support
one another he does the same thing in
our ministries here in the United States
he gets us as ministries competing with
one another you know I've got copyright
on that and I've got caught that message
is copyrighted and it and you got a and
I'm like God gave it to us
let's win souls we don't need to be
divided anymore as well as these
accomplishments dr. Kellogg also off
authored and published one of the most
controversial books ever written on
health and spirituality in the 20th
century it was called the living temple
and I'm not gonna go into too much
detail here because
pastor Bohr and secrets unsealed as well
as a few other men they've done a great
job on the research you can you can you
can get some resources here from this
ministry to help expand on that but I do
want to take a look at a few things
there be not deceived many will depart
from the faith giving heed to seducing
spirits and the doctrines and teachings
of Devils Ellen White said we have now
before us the Alpha of this danger what
danger giving heed to seducing spirits
the Omega will be of a most startling
what's that word nature remember I told
you mark that word down this is
important the Omega will be of a most
startling nature one another come to me
asking me to explain the positions taken
in the living temple and I replied they
are unexplainable the sentiments
expressed do not give a true knowledge
of God we need not the mysticism that is
in this book
for those who entertain these Sophos
trees will soon find themselves in a
position where the enemy can talk with
them and lead them away from God it is
represented to me that the writer of
this book is on a false track or path
and he knows not whither his steps are
tending first selected messages page 202
the theory that God is an essence
pervading all nature is received by many
today who profess to believe the
scriptures but however beautifully
clothed this theory is a most dangerous
deception for it misrepresents God and
it is a dishonor to his greatness and
majesty and it's surely ten
not only to mislead but to debase man it
means instead of being spiritual they
become physically or carnally focused
darkness is its element and sensuality
or the flesh is its fear that's why when
you look at the emerging church they
don't want to talk about doctrine they
want to talk about dialogue and
conversation they want to talk about how
does it make you feel not what is the
word say these theories followed to
their logical conclusion do away with
the necessity for the atonement and they
make man his own Savior the word
atonement there Ellen White in her own
writings she gives the definition of the
word atonement at one mint Jesus's last
prayer before Calvary was father I pray
that they all might be one as I am in
you and as you are in me that they might
be one in us that's what this does away
with the book you're looking at there on
the right this is called building the
living temple a manual for Freemasons
this was released within the last five
years I think it was 2015 but I may be
off I know it was within the last five
years in that amazing
dr. Kellogg's first introduction to
spiritualism and pantheism came at the
age of 21 years old when he and his
brother enrolled in a six-month course
under the instruction of a physician
named Russell trawl director of the
high-g oath therapeutic College in New
York City
dr. trawl taught a doctrine known as
soul identity and the everywhere nosov
god that's Pantha
I'm under a different title after
completing this course Kellogg attended
the Bellevue Hospital Medical School
where he received his MD license in 1875
Kellogg then went on to become the
director in 1876 of the seventh-day
adventists newly renamed Battle Creek
Sanitarium three years after in 1879 dr.
Kellogg married one of the nurses on the
sanitarium staff named Ella or Vella
Eaton Ella Eaton had received her
graduate degree from the Alford Center
in New York City in 1872 and she
continued her education after her
marriage to dr. Kellogg earning her MA
degree in 1885
although united in marriage to dr.
Harvey Kellogg Ella chose to remain a
member of the seventh day Baptist
denomination in which she had been
brought up we also know the seventh day
Baptist were the ones that introduced
the Adventists to the truth about the
Sabbath Ella's strongest spiritual
influences said to have come from the
then-president and pastor of this
University a man named dr. Abram H Lewis
whom she would was eager to introduce to
her husband this is where the influence
of pantheism really began to come in and
in this next message that we're gonna
have this evening we're going to go in
even farther and we're going to start
showing how the roots of this tree began
what we're seeing now is the fruit we're
beginning to see what was happening back
in the 1800s that it wasn't just
coincidence it wasn't just by chance all
of these people were involved in
Hinduism and spiritualism it was through
these works that Satan said I can cause
them to doubt God's Word I know it says
that but it can't
we mean that and the moment we stop
believing what it says we lose all power
let's close with the word of Prayer
Father in Heaven we thank you for your
word which cannot fail we thank you for
your word which was made flesh our Lord
our Savior and our King Jesus Christ
[Music]
you